allison came here for college and that's
where she met this girl
lina one night she found lena dead and
called the police
amanda knox is speaking out against matt
damon's new film
stillwater that's everyone's nightmare
either i'm a psychopath in sheep's
clothing
or i am you the 34 year old writer and
journalist
called out the people involved in the
film that she says profit off her name
face and story without her consent
writing on her website thursday quote
this new film by director tom mccarthy
starring matt damon
is loosely based or directly inspired by
the amanda knox saga
as vanity fair put it in a for-profit
article
promoting a for-profit film neither of
which i am affiliated with
et has reached out to damon mccarthy and
focus features
for comment did you ask her to lie i'm
trying to get my little girl out of jail
that's all i give a damn about
she went on to address vanity fair's use
of the phrase
amanda knox saga writing quote what does
that refer to
does it refer to anything i did no it
refers to the events that resulted from
the murder of meredith kircher
by a burglar named rudy gueyde it refers
to the shoddy police work
prosecutorial tunnel vision and refusal
to admit their mistakes that led the
italian authorities to wrongfully
convict me
twice knox made headlines after she was
wrongfully convicted for the murder of
kercher
a fellow exchange student in 2007. she
then spent the next eight years
fighting for her freedom until she was
acquitted in 2015.
and she was able to tell her side of the
story in the netflix documentary amanda
knox
if i'm guilty it means that i
am the ultimate
figure to fear because i'm not the
obvious one
meanwhile stillwater follows damon as
bill barker
an oil worker from stillwater oklahoma
who travels to france when his estranged
daughter allison
played by abigail breslin is charged
with murdering her friend while studying
in marseilles
i loved her i know you did but everybody
thinks that i killed her
knox went on adding that stillwater is
quote by no means the first thing to rip
off my story without my consent at the
expense of my reputation but she says
she would have liked the chance to speak
with damon and mccarthy to give them
insight before they got involved with
the film quote if you're going to quote
leave the amanda knox case behind and
quote fictionalize
everything around it maybe don't use my
name to promote it
you're not leaving the amanda knox case
behind very well
if every single review mentions me knox
says she understands that damon who is
not a producer on the film and mccarthy
who
is had no obligation to consult her when
telling the story
but she reiterated that she quote never
asked to become a public person
quote my only option is to sit idly by
while others continue to distort my
character
or fight to restore my good reputation
that was wrongfully destroyed it's an
uphill battle i probably won't succeed
but i've been here before
i know what it's like facing impossible
odds
et spoke with mccarthy at the stillwater
premiere in new york city earlier this
month
where the director opened up about the
similarities to knox's life story
when you see the trailer you kind of
think of the amanda knox case but this
is not really taking that story piece by
piece bit by bit so for folks that are
intrigued by
the themes of this story and where it's
going in the trailer how would you
describe it to them
it's a it's a tricky one to describe in
fact i would just say
come and get lost in the movie it goes
to places you don't expect
and i hope engaging and compelling go to
go buy a ticket and get lost
just go sit in a quiet theater alone and
with your family your friends and enjoy